même ma coupe se barrer
frère regarde ce qu' m'a
faitard le mec il mange des chees avec
des pâtes
[Rires]
quoij maisr conneries monit minutes
[Musique]
on me dit que la tou d'alandre commence
préparation la tou est complètement
dstructuré on dirait que le mec s chié
sur la gueule issu du coup il n peut
plus il est sur sa tou depuis maintenant
4h il n'en peut plus son assistante lui
enlève la sueur de la nuque oui il faut
encore aller un petit peu plus loin dans
la touffe aïe AE AE les cheveux s'en
vont tellement il est déterminé par la
touffe yeah
tournageascar saison 2 ça se passe comme
ça jamais sur ma chaise VO tu l' partout
sinon on va te la
voler le
gigolo petite scène de baston là qui
arrive ça va être
cool
[Musique]
[Rires]